[Musique]
un remuant de champagne est un artiste
qui travaille beaucoup puisqu'il va
remuer jusqu'à 70 mille bouteilles par
jean la mousse du champagne autrement
dit l'un des éléments importants de sa
qualité se forment à l'intérieur de la
bouteille par fermentation
mais il ya aussi un dépôt qui se forment
le remuage opération délicate et
régulière consiste à faire glisser ce
dépôt vers le bouchon auquel il va
finalement adhéré entre la vendange et
le bouchon de champagne qui sautent ils
se passent combien de temps à peu près 2
à 3 ans et 5 ans les champagnes
millésimés on s'en occupe de ce
champagne comme d'un véritable enfant il
se repose il vieillit il est remué
toujours la tête en bas et lorsque le
dépôt sera collée aux bouchons on va
plonger le col de la bouteille dans une
solution réfrigérante à moins 20 degrés
un glaçon va en prison dès le dépôt il
ne restera plus qu'à l'expulser
ils vont ensuite remettre un peu de
champagne un peu de liqueur bush est
fixée le bouchon habiller la bouteille
est une fois de plus le champagne
attendra avant le grand jour ouvrir une
bouteille de champagne c'est tout un art
en fait comment doit-on s'y prendre il
faut d'abord penser à faire rafraîchir
la bouteille car le champagne se boit
très frais ensuite l'apprendre
délicatement légèrement inclinée casser
le muselet l'enlever et en tournant
légèrement la bouteille en maintenant le
bouchon ou des bouchers tout doucement
et vous gardez la bouteille incliné et
ensuite vous versez très doucement
il faut pas que le bouchon saute alors
pour éviter surtout regarder respirer à
votre santé
[Musique]